Were these actors not bold enough
to go where no one has gone before?
Or were there other factors behind
their refusal of "Star Trek" roles?
As the human-Vulcan first officer of the
Enterprise and an instant favorite among
the fanbase, Leonard Nimoy's Spock is one of the
most iconic characters on television. While it
may be hard to imagine anyone but Nimoy playing
Spock on "Star Trek: The Original Series," the
actor was reportedly not series creator Gene
Roddenberry's first pick for the part. Instead,
Roddenberry favored comedic actor George
Lindsey, best known for playing the goofy
Goober Pyle on "The Andy Griffith Show"
and its sequel series "Mayberry R.F.D."
In a short television bumper for TVLand, Nimoy
attests that Lindsey was Roddenberry's first
choice for the role that made him a household
name. This claim is corroborated by prolific actor
Ernest Borgnine in his memoir "Ernie,"
recalling that his friend Lindsey
turned the part of Spock down, without
elaborating on the rationale behind the
refusal. Lindsey would continue to
play largely comedic roles on film
and television for the remainder of
his career before his death in 2012.
Another actor reportedly offered the role
of Spock ahead of Nimoy was Academy Award
winner Martin Landau, who had appeared in
high-profile supporting roles in films,
including "North by Northwest." In a
1986 interview with Starlog Magazine,
Landau confirmed he was approached to take the
role of the Vulcan science officer but claimed
he wasn't interested in playing an emotionless
character, unfavorably comparing Spock's stoic
nature to a glorified newscaster. Instead,
he took on a very different television role,
starring as master of disguise Rollin Hand in
the original "Mission: Impossible" TV series.
In a separate interview for "Where No Man
Has Gone Before: A History in Pictures,"
Roddenberry confirmed Landau was being
considered for the role, saying the actor
was a possibility. Elaborating on the potential
casting, Roddenberry attributed Landau's busy
schedule with other projects at the time as the
primary cause behind his turning down the role.
In a coincidental twist, Nimoy replaced Landau
on "Mission: Impossible" as the magician Paris
after Landau left the series in 1969 — several
months after the cancellation of "Star Trek."
"Fascinating."
While developing "Star Trek IV: The Voyage
Home," director and co-writer Leonard Nimoy
learned that popular comedian and actor Eddie
Murphy was apparently a big fan of the franchise.
In a retrospective interview
with The Hollywood Reporter,
co-writer Steve Meerson recalled that an early
script contained a part specifically written
for Murphy, which would have had the comic
powerhouse interact with the Enterprise crew.
Murphy was set to play an astrophysicist at
Berkeley while the "Original Series" crew
visited California's Bay Area in 1986 to save
their timeline by rescuing humpback whales.
"No, I wanna go, I wanna beam up and, you know,
be on the ship, you know, so I didn't do it."
"Yeah no, you have to be on the Enterprise."
Negotiations with Murphy reportedly
broke down before filming began, however,
leading the comedian/actor to drop out from the
project. His planned astrophysicist character
was cut from the story entirely and replaced
with marine biologist Dr. Gillian Taylor,
played by Catherine Hicks. This
provided Kirk with a romantic foil.
Acclaimed actor Edward James Olmos had two close
opportunities to be cast in major "Star Trek"
roles, though he ultimately has yet to appear
in any iteration of the franchise. Director
Leonard Nimoy approached Olmos to play the
villainous Commander Kruge in "Star Trek III:
The Search for Spock" but was
overruled by the producers,
according to William Shatner's memoir
"Star Trek Movie Memories." However,
Olmos' second brush with "Star Trek" saw him
turn down an even bigger opportunity with
the long-running sci-fi franchise that would
have made him an esteemed Starfleet captain.
According to TrekMovie.com, he was
offered to star as Picard in "Star Trek:
The Next Generation," reportedly turning
down the part because of its high level
of commitment and his own schedule at the
time. In an interview with The A.V. Club,
Olmos explained that his decision to return to
sci-fi in "Battlestar Galactica" over his previous
"Star Trek" offer was driven by the quality of
storytelling present in the series' writing.
The late celebrated actor Yaphet Kotto has
starred in a number of fan-favorite projects in
film and television, including a part as Nostromo
technician Dennis Parker in the classic science
fiction horror film "Alien." Kotto nearly took
on an even more iconic sci-fi role as Captain
Jean-Luc Picard, the lead character in "Star Trek:
The Next Generation." According to a BBC interview
with producer Robert Justman, series creator
Gene Roddenberry was initially not enthused by
Patrick Stewart's audition for the part and
looked to other actors to take on the role.
Among the actors who read for the
character was Kotto, who turned down
the part over his concerns about shifting to
television following a prolific film career.
In an interview with The Big Issue, Kotto
reflected on this decision with regret,
referring to his rejection of the chance to
play Picard as a "wrong decision." Ironically,
he would transition to a television career years
later, starring as Baltimore police detective Al
Giardello across the entire run of the acclaimed
crime series "Homicide: Life on the Street."
The 1989 film "Star Trek V: The Final Frontier"
introduces Spock's long-lost older brother Sybok,
who commandeers the Enterprise to
find God at the center of the galaxy.
Played by Laurence Luckinbill, Sybok is
a Vulcan in touch with and open about his
emotions. The character was written for Sean
Connery, fresh off of his Academy Award-winning
performance in "The Untouchables," but
the Scottish actor turned down the part.
According to TrekMovie.com, Connery rejected the
role due to his commitments to appear in "Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade." Despite Connery's
absence in "The Final Frontier," the film's
holy planet Sha Ka Ree was named after him as a
subtle nod to the intended casting. Years later,
it was revealed that a different actor, very
familiar to Trekkies, apparently vied for the
Sybok role unsuccessfully. In an interview with
StarTrek.com, Luckinbill claims that Nimoy lobbied
to play Sybok for a dual role in "Star Trek V" but
was rejected because the siblings weren't twins.
"Excuse me, I find that
selection highly illogical."
As "Star Trek: The Next Generation" steadily
grew in popularity across its seven-season run,
the writers wanted to find a way to include actor
and comedian Robin Williams in a guest appearance.
Williams was a self-professed fan of "Star
Trek," even going so far as to reference the
franchise directly in his hit sci-fi sitcom
"Mork and Mindy." The writers created a part
specifically for Williams in the Season 5 episode
"A Matter of Time" as Berlinghoff Rasmussen,
a time-traveling conman scheming to
steal Starfleet technology for himself.
Unfortunately, scheduling conflicted with
the 1991 Steven Spielberg film "Hook," which
prevented him from appearing on "The Next
Generation." Rasmussen was instead played
by actor Matt Frewer, best known for his
'80s cult classic character Max Headroom.
Kim Cattrall appeared in "Star Trek VI:
The Undiscovered Country" as Valeris,
Spock's young Vulcan protege on the
Enterprise and the starship's new
helmsman after Sulu is given his own command.
Though Valeris is eventually revealed to be
a traitor and part of the conspiracy to
assassinate Klingon chancellor Gowron,
Cattrall nearly had a continuing future with
the wider "Star Trek" franchise on television.
However, rather than reprising her role as
the duplicitous Vulcan Valeris, Cattrall was
offered the part of Bajoran security officer
Kira Nerys in "Star Trek: Deep Space Nine."
In a leaked casting memo for "Deep Space
Nine" from 1992, Cattrall is among the
names appearing near the top of the list to play
the no-nonsense Bajoran freedom fighter. She is
cited in the memo as passing on the role, though
no further explanation behind her decision is
included in the document. Cattrall would find
considerable success elsewhere on television,
starring as the vivacious businesswoman
and socialite Samantha Jones — a role
she also nearly turned down — in the
acclaimed HBO series "Sex and the City."
There are plenty of other names on the leaked
casting memo for Kira in "Deep Space Nine," all
of whom are listed as a pass or unavailable. Next
to Cattrall, the most notable actor on the list
is Rita Wilson — prolific television and film
actor, and wife of lifelong "Star Trek" fan Tom
Hanks. However, like Cattrall and the other actors
under consideration, Wilson turned down the role,
with the memo citing she wasn't interested
in working in television at the time.
Interestingly, Nana Visitor, who ultimately was
cast as Kira for "Deep Space Nine" and "Star Trek:
Lower Decks" is not among the names listed on the
memo. Visitor's agent cautioned her against taking
the role, feeling it would be detrimental
to her career. But as Variety explains,
she was impressed by the character and accepted.
Wilson has gone on to play numerous supporting
roles in film and television, notably as recurring
characters on "The Good Wife" and "Girls."
While Kate Mulgrew may be best known for
bringing Kathryn Janeway to life in the
television shows "Star Trek: Voyager" and "Star
Trek: Prodigy," she was not the first actor cast
in the role. Academy Award-nominated actor
Geneviève Bujold was initially cast as the
"Voyager" commanding officer, Captain Nicole
Janeway, maintaining the role as principal
photography began in 1994. However, as The
New York Times reports, two days into filming,
Bujold decided to quit the series over concerns
regarding the show's demanding work schedule.
"Keeping me awake for four days
straight with the constant pain
of your devices drilling into my skull."
Mulgrew, who was among the actors that
initially read for the role of Janeway
during the casting process, was called back
in the wake of Bujold's sudden departure and
accepted the lead part. With the character renamed
Kathryn Janeway to reflect the shift in actors,
Mulgrew quickly brought the memorable captain
to life as filming resumed. For her part,
Bujold returned to focus primarily on
film work with the occasional TV movie;
she never starred as the lead in a television
series across her distinguished career.
Audiences were treated to a bold reinvention of
the "Star Trek" franchise in 2009, with filmmaker
J.J. Abrams helming a reboot movie that recast
the classic characters from "The Original Series."
Among the iconic crew reimagined for the
film was Spock, played by Zachary Quinto
across the trilogy as a Vulcan with a fiery
temper under his stoic exterior. However,
Quinto was not the only actor in consideration
for the role; Academy Award winner Adrien
Brody was approached by Abrams to potentially
portray the Enterprise's logical first officer.
In an interview with MTV, Brody confirmed
he spoke with Abrams about playing Spock
in the 2009 "Star Trek," even sharing
the news of his potential casting with
his parents. Though he expressed
regret about not taking the part,
he has not fully divulged specifics as to why
he didn't appear as the iconic science officer.
With a new, younger cast of the "Original
Series" era front and center in the 2009
"Star Trek," one of the actors widely rumored to
be considered to play James Kirk was Matt Damon.
Damon himself publicly dismissed the casting
as internet rumors, observing that the reboot
was looking for a younger actor for the role.
However, months after the movie was released,
it was revealed that Damon was being
considered for a different character.
Abrams confirmed that he did approach Damon
for a role in the film, later clarifying in
an interview with MTV that he spoke to
him about playing James Kirk's father,
George. Abrams revealed that Damon
graciously turned down the role,
so Australian actor Chris Hemsworth
played the ill-fated George Kirk instead.
2013's "Star Trek Into Darkness" is a strange
sequel, offering a loose retread of "Star Trek II:
The Wrath of Khan" within the storytelling
sensibilities of the reboot timeline that began
in 2009. The film pits the Enterprise crew against
the genetically enhanced superhuman Khan Noonien
Singh — the classic villainous role originated by
Ricardo Montalban. Academy Award winner Benicio
del Toro entered negotiations to play the reboot
timeline's iteration of Khan during a time when
the identity of the movie's antagonist remained
unconfirmed in the face of mounting speculation.
According to Vulture, Del Toro decided to
drop out of "Into Darkness" after salary
negotiations broke down — approximately one month
before filming was scheduled to begin. Instead,
English actor Benedict Cumberbatch played Khan in
the final film. "Into Darkness" endured criticism
for casting a Caucasian actor as Khan, while
director J.J. Abrams admitted attempting to
keep Khan's true identity a secret was
a mistake. Del Toro would go on to play
two very different sci-fi roles in "Star Wars:
The Last Jedi" and "Guardians of the Galaxy."